um
people were
really um obsessed with the girl from
plainville story it's very dark it's
everywhere in the news right now
tell me what drew you to it
you know i followed the case in real
time when it was happening and i think
that like most people i was completely
shocked and titillated by the story
um in a way that i think i look back on
now and and feel differently i think
that the documentary that came out on
hbo uh really shifted my thought about
this uh and we're sort of looking back
at women
and how we've treated
young women in the media in a different
way whether it's britney spears or paris
hilton or monica lewinsky
and this is a young girl who did
something pretty horrific
but our titillation with that
is also something to be examined and i
think this is a retelling that gives
these two children
a real
a real uh retelling oh that's so
interesting
um this was really interesting i am a
crossword fanatic i am obsessed and
people loved you from you are the worst
and there's a crossword story there tell
me about it
basically all my dreams came true and i
was in the new york times crossword
that's so huge
[Applause]
what did will short give for you as a
clue because he really does like to mind
twist people yeah this was not so
complicated i think i'm obscure enough
that they could just say
cash actress of you're the worst i like
that it's straightforward and i can work
with that
it's uh i don't like being sent down a
rabbit hole upon another rabbit hole
upon another rabbit hall
um although you know what rabbit hall i
could get into like every time i've seen
it probably 10 times the wolf of wall
street which you are in
one of my favorite movies of all time
what was it like to work with the one
and only leonardo di caprio
this is the big reveal he's a horrible
human being
uh i will
no he knows everyone's name he's kind he
works hard he knows his lines he's just
absolutely lovely he spent he also works
very hard he had this scene where he was
um eating sushi he and jonah they're
eating sushi and they improv for like
two hours and uh leo
uh you know is actually eating sushi
during all of that and and had to take
little breaks to actually um relieve
himself into a bucket between
the tanks and that's that's commitment
you know when that you really love
someone like kind of like your child
you're like i wouldn't mind watching leo
throw
up just
well it was all rainbows and unicorns
coming out of him i bet it was i knew it
i knew it
[Music]
you